hey listen to high school we used to
choke each other out that's like a theme
to go unchecked me out oh no no no no no
no no no Eddie don't do it please don't
chuck him unconscious no no please let's
go you must not be [ __ ] you know what
let me tell you a story first back when
I used to work at the strip club he only
takes like 20 seconds back when I was a
blue belt 1995 I worked at strip club
and there was this girl I was dating she
was a bartender she was seriously 4 foot
10 and surely bartenders and waitresses
always the best-looking strip clubs let
him I will
she was she was 92 pounds bartender the
smallest girl
and I showed her how to do a rear-naked
her she was tiny her name was Kimmy and
the strip club manager was your size big
like he used to be buffed but fat-ass
yeah but used to be Bob I'll tell you
that he bought football player type big
manager and he didn't believe in
jiu-jitsu at all and he said if she
could choke me out with one of them
jujitsu moves I'll give her the keys to
my Corvette so she had to literally get
on a barstool had to go around I mean
she was like that's bad anyways like
this and then he went out lights out so
he hits the ground and then he pops back
up you know what the [ __ ] I thought he
faked it people usually don't hit the
ground pop back up
usually they hit the ground they're done
and they need an ambulance right but he
popped right back up I said what
happened like [ __ ] you need to give her
your Corvette was it was a 7th grade
during lunch the kids would choke each
other out you put your hands up on their
neck but then it'd be like the
cheerleaders that wanted to be choked
out they would show this not if I do
about three where did you go to school